we were hearing a powerful new
perspective on sexual assault from
survivors Chanel Miller the once
anonymous woman was attacked by former
Stanford swimmer Brock Turner while she
was unconscious
Turner was convicted of three felony sex
crimes he served just 90 days in jail
and registered as a sex offender for
life for 60 minutes she read the victim
impact statement from court that was
shared around the world we spoke to her
yesterday what did you want us to get
out of the victim impact statement I
hope you heard in it that there was
self-love that there's a lot of power in
anger anger is usually dissing courage
we want to tame the victim and have her
be composed when really for me it was
wonderful I was depressed for so long
when I finally felt anger it was a sign
that I was stepping on my own side and
ready to fight for myself because you
write in the books you know that people
want victims to be inspiring yeah this
has happened to you yes you can talk
about it now let's move on and you get
it life is not that neat yeah oh yeah
it's so damn hard I don't know how
anyone gets through it like this all the
time it's okay to have panic attacks
it's okay to lash out and have periods
of depression all of that is very normal
given these circumstances I wanted to
normalize all the phases that you will
go through and not feel like you're
behind or you're being dramatic you know
more than 18 million people looked at
that victim impact statement it was put
online by BuzzFeed they asked her
permission she said she never expected
that reaction Hillary Clinton mentioned
it they read it on Capitol Hill in
Congress it was used in classrooms and
she said she was very gratified she felt
bombarded by kindness after what she had
been doing lovely bombarded by that
phrase yeah exactly right coming up in
our next hour Chanel Miller offers her
message to other survivors and shares
the response she received after after
revealing her identity on 60 minutes on
Sunday